Health officials, battling the first flu pandemic in 41 years, got some good news recently.
Just one dose of vaccine appears to protect most adults.
US Secretary of Health Kathleen Sebelius said, the news was encouraging.
It now appears that most of the folks have a robust immune response...
...in eight to ten days from the date of the first vaccine, which is very positive news.
A US vaccine study has proven to be just as effective as a vaccine trial in Australia.
The news is surprising and welcome.
With more vaccine available,...
...this means, the H1N1 vaccine can inoculate twice as many people throughout the world.
Dr. Anthony Fauci is with the US National Institutes of Health.
In essence, it mitigates some of the problems that we're talking about...
...when you talk about decreased or not decreased, but inadequate supplies for everyone.
US health officials say, 98% of the flu cases they're seeing are caused by the H1N1 virus.
The vaccine should be available by mid-October.
But schools are already open.
The weather is turning cooler.
And the flu season is under way in the northern hemisphere.